least a critical injury crash and a
completely closed freeway normally we
start with Sherry talking about the
weather but when we have a freeway
closure want to make sure you are aware
coming out of the spaghetti Bowl heading
towards the rainbow curve you're gonna
have to get off at Jones a multiple car
critical injury crash at the rainbow
curve again no confirmed fatality at
this hour and it's a little bit hard to
tell from this picture but this is the
95 kind of going around the rainbow
curve there's at least one rolled over
vehicle somebody else on the exit ramp
to get off at Summerlin Parkway so
multiple cars involved the bottom line
you're being diverted off the 95 at
Jones so you're saying well that's all
great but how do I get back on the
freeway we have two suggestions for you
first of all you can go north on Jones
up to Lake Mead and then take Lake Mead
West that'll be your next exit if you're
going north on Jones now you can also go
south on Jones down to Alta or to
Charleston get over to Rainbow and then
go north on Rainbow that'll get you on
to the 95. the rest of the freeway
looking like a regular Rush Hour again
we'll keep you posted with the complete
closure of the 95 at Jones